et avec nous pour en parler laurent
alexandre essayiste et chirurgien jean
philippe du coin clément maire udi de
mennecy vice-président du conseil
régional d'ile-de-france bonsoir à tous
les deux merci d'être avec nous sur
l'antenne d'arte et france un peu d'eux
trente mille cas quotidiens donc un
coronavirus et environ 300 morts par
jour en france et ce qu'on appelle un
plateau haut il y at-il vraiment une
décroissance de l'épidémie depuis le
début de la campagne de vaccination
comme le dit le ministre de la santé à
laurent alexandre on a une baisse de la
mortalité chez les plus âgés et
notamment dans les ehpad
mais on n'a pas d'amélioration sur le
front des réanimations parce que les
personnes âgées en ehpad n'ont jamais
été envoyé en réanimation donc
l'augmentation de la vaccination dans
les ehpad ne diminue pas la pression sur
les réanimations ça diminue juste le
nombre total de morts c'est à dire des
morts hospitalière plus les morts en
ehpad
donc aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation difficile où le faible taux de
vaccination des gens âgés qui ne sont
pas en ehpad ne permet pas encore
d'avoir une amélioration dans le taux de
malades en réanimation et de malades
graves
j'en finis par dans des bois clémence
est vrai que les avis sont son cadre et
contradictoire sur un progrès ou non
clairement at on les moyens d'une
réouverture début mai dans ces
conditions je le rappelle un peu de
30000 quatre quotidiens par jour 300
morts par jour en france les trois morts
par jour en france et chaque jour un
boeing l'interview ce qui se cache
après la réalité après un an après un
troisième confinement c'est qu'il ya une
attente extrêmement forte de beaucoup
beaucoup de français pour pouvoir
recommencer à avoir une vie mais à
pouvoir avoir quelques activités
culturelles quelques activités sociales
c'est le fait que l'angleterre ou
l'espagne réouvert des terrasses qu' un
certain nombre d'annoncés ont été
entamées par le pouvoir par le
gouvernement est donc cet espoir et
cette attente est le chien
beaucoup beaucoup de gens après la
réalité la pression speed nrf très élevé
j'étais vendredi d'or sur les visites
des réalisations d'un hôpital en
seine-et-marne où effectivement la
baisse du taux d'incidence ne se traduit
pas encore aujourd'hui en termes de
moins de deux passions au moins de
malades et avec pour le coup plutôt une
diminution des moyenne d'âge des
patients hospitalisés en réelle du
chiffre alors vous venez de le dire dans
certains endroits du monde la vie
reprend près l'épidémie a une vue
progressive des mesures sanitaires la
californie israël le royaume uni on va
regarder ces images qui nous font un
petit peu de mal faut bien le dire
largement diffusée déjà celle de boris
johnson qui nous narguent buvant une
bière dans le sens du du pays
hier laurent alexandre clairement est ce
qu'on peut en espérer
de même dans un avenir plus ou moins
proche
selon vous ben ça va être un petit peu
difficile parce que il ne vous a pas
échappé que la france aura le taux de
vaccination anglais dans trois mois
la france a trois mois de retard sur
l'angleterre en matière de taux de
vaccination là deux mois de retard sur
les etats-unis
elle a six mois de retard sur israël
sert que la france aura le taux de
vaccination d'aujourd'hui en israël en
septembre
c'est à dire six mois de retard donc le
de confinement va se faire
progressivement pour des raisons
politiques
nous sommes à un an de la présidentielle
l'échec de la politique vaccinale du
gouvernement qui est lié aux mauvaises
négociations européennes sur les vaccins
conduit à un énorme retard de l'union
européenne dont la france mais ça n'est
plus potable
les images de tous les pays qui déconfit
d'aujourd'hui met une pression sur le
président la république énorme compte
tenu de la proximité des échéances pas
tellement les régionales les élections
locales qui sont perdus pour le pouvoir
mais où la présidentielle tient la
campagne pour les présidentielles va
commencer dans six mois
le président ne peut pas maintenir une
pression aussi forte
au moment où tout le monde des confits
de dire que le boris johnson n'a
à juste titre le président de la
république française
et ces images vont faire de plus en plus
de mal politiquement si l'on est sinon
le réseau n'est que d'un point de vue
épidémiologique il faudrait maintenir un
confinement encore plus fort pendant un
deux mois mais ce n'est pas socialement
possible les français ne le supporterait
pas et ce n'est pas politiquement
possible de corelli t on va prendre un
risque médical et des mieux logique
parce que la situation politico-sociale
ne permet pas de le continuer à confiner
mais notre immense retard vaccinale
justifierait on retarde le déconfinement
mais en tant que citoyen et je ne le
souhaite pas aujourd'hui parce que les
effets secondaires même médicaux de ces
confinement à répétition sont maintenant
trop élevé il faudra réfléchir aux
raisons qui ont fait que que la france
et l'europe sont tellement tromper dans
la négociation des contrats de vaccins
et ont pris des mois et des mois de
retard sur les autres pays développés
mais on ne pleure pas sur du lait
renversé
aujourd'hui il faut contester là il faut
constater la réalité on va devoir et
ouvrir sur un plateau haut parce qu'il
n'est plus possible de maintenir les
gens fouillent bloch plus longtemps ça
fait six mois qu'ils resteront fermés
ça fait six mois que la culture est
complètement bloquée sur n'est plus
tenable
jean philippe dugoin clément en
substance que nous dira laurent
alexandre c'est que la décision sera
forcément politique et pas dictée par
voilà d'aider des vraies raisons
sanitaires
ça veut dire qu'on va choisir le cynisme
qu'on va choisir finalement de sacrifier
des gens il y aura des gens qui vont
mourir parce que voilà il faudra des
confiné pour des raisons politiques et
toute décision est ferme et sa politique
le fait de confier le premier le
deuxième ou troisième tranquillement le
fait de ne pas confier des profs ont
pensé qu'on allait sur la même
trajectoire que l'espagne de
l'angleterre fin janvier février ou
aujourd'hui de les confier tout ça n'est
que des choix politiques
le choix politique c'est l'arbitrage
entre la demande sanitaire la demande
économique la demande sociale dont deux
fois et par nature purement politique au
sens
noble du terme d'ailleurs après la
réalité aussi c'est que maintenir le
confinement tel qu'il est aujourd'hui ça
va devenir extrêmement difficile tenir
là confinement en avril mai juin quand
les journées rallongent qu'il fait beau
c'est beaucoup plus difficile que de
faire en hiver en janvier et février
quand il fait nuit à 18h30 c'est aussi
une réalité tenir un confinement après
un an
c'est plus difficile de tenir après neuf
ou dix mois
donc il ya aussi cette réalité avec qui
existe et moi je met quand même
extrêmement regarde quand on parle du
fait de dire en ré ouvre est-ce qu'il y
aura une explosion à ce qui aura des
morts supplémentaires qu'elles sont et
aujourd'hui la réalité c'est que
personne ne le connaît le bilan
sanitaire sur le nom test le certaines
pathologies non prise en charge des
enfants filmant successifs on a eu en
bien personne ne se font plus dépisté ne
se font pas testé combien de pathologie
du fait des annulations des reports
d'opérations qui sont faites sur les
hôpitaux ne sont pas prises à temps
voirie les effets plus graves
donc la réalité c'est que le confinement
génère un certain nombre de protections
par rapport à la copie
mais y compris la fin de l'été aux
autres problèmes à vue et la réalité
c'est que la globalité la photo global
de la facture des choix politiques ont
été faits depuis un an encore une fois
tout est politique on l'a ne durera que
dans quelques mois ou dans quelques
années alors il ya des gens qui sont
encore plus pessimistes ans c'est le cas
du président du conseil scientifique
jean françois delfraissy
pour lui la sortie qui ne s'est vraiment
pas pour demain et côté on aura
probablement à l'automne de nouveau une
circulation virale importante mais on
aura une large population vaccinée je
vois une sortie de crise définitive plus
tôt en 2022 en 2022 laurent alexandre je
m'adresse aux au docteur que vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes aussi pessimiste
que jean françois delfraissy aujourd'hui
en temps en temps que médecin je suis
aujourd'hui convaincu que mes collègues
et moi nous devons tous faire une crise
d'humilité nous nous sommes beaucoup
trompé et sur nos pronostics
épidémiologique donc faire des
pronostics à 6 - nord j'incite tous mes
collègues a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de prudence et je ne suis pas ce que
peut être une bonne politique de
paniquer les gens aujourd'hui je pense
vraiment et les derniers chiffres sur
l'impact des campagnes vaccinales dans
les pays qui ont vacciné vite sont très
bons et nous nous incite à l'optimiste à
l'optimisme je pense qu'il faut vacciner
plus vite mais en france on vaccine
encore lentement
avant-hier on a vacciné 82 mille
personnes c'est-à-dire 0 12% de la
population les états unis l'angleterre
thaksin autour de 1 % par jour israël
vacciner 1 500 par jour donc la
vaccination est cargo continue en france
je pense qu'au lieu de paniquer les
français comme le fait d'être ici
il faudrait qu'on aille plus vite sur la
vaccination et qu'on rattrape les pays
qui ont vacciné vite parce que c'est
notre seule chance de nous en sortir
et personnellement je pense que si on
vaccine plus vite on devrait avoir un
pic d'automne beaucoup plus faible à
moins malheureusement qu'il y ait de
nouveaux variants qui deviennent
résistants au vaccin mais pour l'instant
en réalité les variants que l'on voit
aujourd'hui reste sensible fortement ou
assez fortement au vaccin notamment au
vaccin est raide message est alors
alexandre sens que la vaccination en
accéléré ça semble être un voeu pieux
aujourd'hui regardez cette image qui
fait mal hein illustration dans le
centre de paris c'était dimanche
ce centre tout simplement vides avec des
pompiers qui attendent sagement dehors
voilà c'est pas la foule des grands
jours on précise que ce centre
dispensé de l'astra est née card
malheureusement dont beaucoup se méfient
que vous inspirent ces images jean
philippe dugoin clément alors que
laurent alexandre vient de nous le
rappeler il faut absolument vacciner
vacciner vacciner ont-elles une
succession d'erreurs aux questions de
communication vous prendre l'exemple
encore une fois l'angleterre en
angleterre avec signer massivement au
astrazeneca
le nombre de cas graves d'accidents et
au astrazeneca
il s'approche de la chance ou la
malchance de gagner au loto
la réalité c'est que en ayant un premier
ministre une île dimanche soir il ya
trois semaines et a aucun problème sur
le havre à l'elysée qui le lundi revient
dessus quand on suspend pendant quelques
jours sur quelque chose où les peurs et
est très restreinte sur le vaccin
on a recréé une peur et on a donné
l'impression qu'ils avaient le médecin
du riche vaccin duo j'avais le vaccin de
low cost et on a collé cette étiquette
et sur leurs trois aînées temps et ce
qui est absolument terrible c'est qu'à
monter en charge de la vaccination elle
ne peut se faire qu'avec l'ensemble des
vaccins si elle le fera
le johnson sur lequel on est en train de
créer la même peur ou le même plaignant
n'est uniquement sur le cuiseur ça va
prendre beaucoup plus de temps
donc je crois ce qui est urgent
aujourd'hui pour éviter d'avoir ainsi
une situation de pénurie qui dure est-ce
qu'on est plutôt en train de commencer
en sortir sur le nombre de vaccins
khiari c'est de ré expliquer et de
richesse et de rassurer les gens travail
qui a été fait en décembre janvier
février et pour tous les vaccins on est
obligé de leur ferme d'accord sur
l'estrade du fait d'erreurs de
communication
laurent alexandre votre collègue argent
jean philippe dubois clément du jour
relais la cité se johnson & johnson qui
a eu le feu vert aujourd'hui de l'agencé
européenne du médicament
ça va être voilà le même scénario que
pour astrazeneca c'est à dire un échec
cuisant annoncé par ce qu'ont fait les
choses moins bien est ce qu'il n'ya que
ça où les français sont particulièrement
réticent et sceptique par rapport aux
britanniques
on paye l'erreur de communication du
président de la république depuis
décembre le 4 décembre dernier
macron donne une interview à brut et il
explique les dangers de la vaccination
devant le journaliste de brut
c'est l'époque où en angleterre on se
lance dans la vaccination pour aller
très vite
quelques semaines plus tard la reine
d'angleterre et boris johnson sont
vaccinés publiquement pour donner
confiance comme le roi du maroc s'est
fait vacciner publiquement olivier
jean castex au ciel très tardivement et
uniquement quand il ya eu la catastrophe
avec les gens qui refusait de se faire
vacciner
donc la communication en france a été
catastrophique
saint décembre fischer a tenu des
discours sur les dangers
monsieur vaccination du gouvernement a
tenu des discours complètement
pessimiste incroyablement inquiétant sur
la vaccination
même moi qui suis un pro vaccin
absolument acharnée j'aurai fini par
être paniqué par fisher fin fin décembre
notamment dans ses interviews sur europe
1 donc la communication du gouvernement
a été une communication
contre-productive l'état à paniquer les
français et puis l'interruption de
l'astra et des cas pendant quatre jours
a été absolument désastreuse
on a beaucoup beaucoup moins de chance
de faire un caillou sous astra que
d'être foudroyée ou d'être piquée par
une de mourir d'une piqûre de vipère en
france le dos de de caillou est beaucoup
plus faible que chez les fumeurs il est
beaucoup plus faible que chez les femmes
qui prennent la pilule
la probabilité de faire un caillou elle
est de l'ordre de 2 cas par million au
maximum
c'est un taux absolument extrêmement
faible le risque de mourir quand on
n'est pas vacciner beaucoup plus
important moi personnellement étant
médecin j'ai été vacciné très tôt donc
au finder
mais j'ai prescrit un astrazeneca ma
femme ma femme a été vaccinées hier à la
ce tracé des cas et je n'ai pas le monde
la moindre inquiétude sur le risque
elle prendrait un risque beaucoup plus
important à ne pas s'être excité donc
j'ai un site vos auditeurs à se
précipiter pour aller se faire vacciner
par l'as train et par le johnsen plutôt
que de finir en réanimation dans un mois
et face à la peur de certains français
concernant ce vaccin astrazeneca
vous le maire 1
de même si en ile de france dénonce
aussi le gâchis des vaccins en raison du
manque de civisme de personnes qui
n'honorent pas leurs rendez vous auquel
est la situation sur place parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a tous autour de nous
des personnes qui ont peut-être eu la
chance de se faire vacciner en fin de
journée quand il avait l'idée
éventuellement d'aller dans les centres
mais beaucoup de personnes qui prennent
rendez vous sur d'autres taux libre
d'autolib ne vont tout simplement pas
honoré leur rendez vous ça existe ça
aussi sur le terrain monsieur le maire
oui alors la réalité c'est que d'un
centre de vaccination à l'autre on
s'organise pour éviter erdre des doses
sur le centre fermé comme une andouille
six heures dont il ya moins de refus sur
le à traou effectivement on a créé ce
phénomène de refuser absolument fou
quand on voit la tante de beaucoup de
gens et 1 quand on a des gens qui ne
prennent pas eh bien avec les médecins
avec les affaires de l'équipe sur place
pourraient à elles en fin de journée des
personnes à des des gens dont on sait
qu'ils sont en attente et qu'on va
perdre s'il pouvait venir dans une demi
heure trois quart d'heure où vous prend
vous passez en vaccination et on a la
même chose qui se fait sur les
pharmaciens qui distance du astrazeneca
puisque pour le coup on est en droit de
vacciner en phrases et des cas on leur
terme et pour faciliter les choses de
son groupe et sur une salle communale
plutôt que de faire au cou le coup dans
leur pharmacie et on est l'exemple
dimanche dernier il restait trois doses
en fin de journée et on a réussi à
trouver entre les pharmaciens et les
personnes municipaux des gens
correspondant aux critères qu'ils
étaient prêts à se faire vacciner mais
ça nécessite d'avoir beaucoup de
souplesse et ça nécessite vraiment
j'insiste sur le problème du astra qui
refusait à beaucoup de gens lui par de
rassurer de d'essayer d'éteindre des
peurs et je pense aussi pour la question
du à frasne d'ouvrir plus largement
c'est le plus largement en nombre le
plus le rapport entre l'offre et la
demande
il est fort et donc le monde aura
peut-être aujourd'hui on a créé tout
seul un schéma de perte des sanglots
le mot de la fin pour vous laurent
alexandre les 600 millions de doses au
livret de father en europe par
l'annonceur
il ya deux jours est ce que ça va nous
nous sauver quand même une lueur
d'espoir oui on va s'en sortir mais avec
beaucoup de retard et moi je fais partie
des gens qui sont scandalisés par ce
waterloo vaccinale il faudra une enquête
il faudra à comprendre pourquoi l'union
européenne c'est à ce point plantés dans
les contrats à quel point la mails
apprécier la réalité du marché vaccinale
et de l'organisation de la production de
vaccins l'europe prend des mois de
retard à cause de cette énorme plantage
de l'union européenne
cela ne peut pas rester impuni merci à
tous les deux laurent alexandre jean
philippe dugoin clément d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france ce soir